>> This is where LSTMs come in.
LSTM stands for long short-term memory.
Now, conceptually, a recurrent neural
network consists of a repetition of
simple little units like this,
which take as an input the past,
a new inputs, and produces a new
prediction and connects to the future.
Now, what's in the middle of that is
typically a simple set of layers.
Some weights and some linearities.A
typical neural network.
With LSTMs,
we're going to replace this little
module with a strange little machine.
It will look complicated, but
it's still functionally a neural net.
And you can drop it into your RNN and
not worry about it.
Everything else about the architecture
remains the same, and
it greatly reduces
the vanishing gradient problem.